well you may not have heard about this
since apparently it's not a big news
story somehow but UFOs turn out to be
real we're not kidding recently the New
York Times profiled a secret 22 million
dollar Pentagon program that
investigated unidentified flying objects
doesn't mean they're from outer space
but they're not identified and they're
flying and they're objects the program
wasn't bogus investigators found
multiple aircraft encounters that could
not explain and the humans storing metal
alloy recovered from the vicinity of
these encounters Leslie Cain wrote about
this in the New York Times that piece in
question and she also wrote a book
called UFO generals pilots and
government officials go on the record
she spent years investigating UFOs with
support of former Bill Clinton chief of
staff by the way John Podesta as Lee
came joins us tonight Leslie thanks for
coming on thanks for having me Tucker so
that piece I think vindicated a lot of
work that you've been doing for an
awfully long time and certainly got my
attention and I've stopped making fun of
people like you and started started
paying attention I this seems like a
huge story so I know that it's it's vast
and hard to sum up but if you could just
briskly tell us what we think we know
about these sightings well we do know
that there are objects in the sky and
sometimes in the water that demonstrate
extraordinary capabilities that we but
that experts say we don't have on this
planet we don't have the capability of
creating the kind of technology that are
apparent technology that's been observed
by high-level officials for many many
decades the Pentagon program is the most
recent discovery but these things have
been studied in other countries and by
our country for many years so what
percentage of these settings are we sure
are not weather phenomena or
experimental aircraft well that's a
really good question because most
sightings of UFOs that just people
report are not are identifiable I mean
we're talking about a very maybe five to
ten percent of all the sightings that
are called in are not explainable and
what the ones that are really of
interest are the ones reported by
military pilots by commercial pilots by
trained observers multiple witnesses
ones that are caught on radar events
that have a lot of data to support them
and involve very very credible people so
I guess what bothers me most about this
story is how clearly people who should
have been following up and paying attend
and haven't been in the case that sticks
with me November seventh I think 2006 at
Chicago O'Hare Airport 4:15 in the
afternoon
gate C 25 I believe the pilot of the
plane waiting to depart to Charlotte
looks up and there is a saucer hovering
not that far over the point people in
the tower see it other pilots see it
dozens people see it it's real and the
FAA refuses to investigate how could
that be I know it's shocking it's
absolutely shocking to me I mean they
they refused to investigate I think
because they I mean who knows what the
bigger the bigger reason probably is
that it's very they can't explain these
things and they just won't you know they
don't want to deal with them it might
frighten people they don't have enough
information they don't like to say well
there's something hovering above an
airport where we don't know what it was
so basically they will come up with
other explanations for it such as that
it was a weather phenomenon that's what
the FAA said about O'Hare which is
really an insult to the pilots who
witnessed this thing and many other
observers who know that it wasn't
weather I mean it was a metallic-looking
disc shape object that hovered over the
as you said hovered over a terminal is
gates a c-17 for about five minutes and
then it shot straight up through the
clouds this was an incredible aspect of
the thing it was hovering below a cloud
Bank and all of a sudden it just shot
straight up really fast through the
cloud Bank and cut a hole in it so there
was like a cookie cutter clean hole in
the clouds you could look up and see the
blue on the other side and you know as
far as anybody knows as far as I know
and from what I've been told we don't
have machines in the sky that can do
things like but I mean this is not a
potato field in Maine in the 1950s at
3:00 in the morning this is Chicago
O'Hare one of the biggest business
airports in the world in the middle of
the day in front of sobra witnesses
including pilots and the control tower
and the FAA says we're not that
interested like how could that be I know
I mean I it's it's very by appreciate
how baffled you are Tucker because I'm
baffle too and you can imagine that the
witness is involved with this you know
it's an insult to them I mean there are
many witnesses and we're talking about
military people you know high-level
people in the Air Force the Navy the
other military commercial pilots who are
just told that they're we're not
interested in what they saw and it's
very difficult for a lot of them because
they're patriotic people well yeah I
mean but what if it's the Chinese
military I mean I
I believe you because you are I think
the preeminent researcher on this
question but it beggars belief that the
US government would just sort of let it
go anyway I appreciate Leslie thank you
for coming on it's an honor to have you
thanks a lot Tucker I appreciate your
interest in this thank you thanks a
million